here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show I'm gonna ask some of
these questions but first we didn't get
to your book on the show and I wanted to
and a lot of people watching here now I
wanted to ask you this question he said
tip and the Gipper when politics worked
but I remember we did an editorial a few
weeks ago about Ronald Reagan and I
think we called him patient zero for
everything that's wrong with the country
now I mean he certainly was the guy who
tripled the debt deregulation yeah
voodoo economics cutting them taxes for
the rich race-baiting
I could go on socialized medicine where
did they get that from maybe to politics
worked a little better if Tip O'Neill
had said no no the fact is that he did
many times he was the lone voice out
there for two or three years all by
himself I was standing next to him let
me tell you this country was on a roll
in reagan's direction what he did you
may disagree with but he thought the
election of 1980 counted he thought
Reagan won big time that's he said he
had or he said he had a right to a
honeymoon in an up or down vote
you would have logjam to be able to
probably filibustered him denied him his
vote tip said no I'm not gonna deny this
guy's vote he got elected when did the
rot really set in new I know that
concern well the kenra the Conservatives
say Bork the Conservatives same right
what Jim Rohn there's one thing Jim
Wright didn't do we kept the clock going
in one of the votes when they had it
each eat it one night and that's true
they had a big part of it and he kept it
but new came in there and said keep your
wife back in the district that was a big
deal can't bring back don't get social
in Washington don't get to know anybody
it also caused all kinds of problems in
marriages and he did that on purpose tip
would always say bring your wife here if
you can oh well I think we know why Newt
didn't want to do that
okay so it's like the way you tell the
best stuff Oliver let's talk about JFK
for a second because obviously you're
very associated from your yellow movie
and the 50th anniversary is coming up in
about a month and a half I guess yeah
any thoughts on the 50th anniversary and
anything you would have done differently
in telling the movie you made all those
years ago no I I would say the movie
holds up very nicely in fact in the
light of the fact of area there Snowden
and all the Bush line about weapons of
mass destruction we know now we now know
that governments lie and we accept that
much more so than when the movie came
out in 1991 and Jim Garrison for all the
scandal and calumny that was thrown at
him was actually like a Snowden and a
Julian Assange actually one of the first
people who tried to bring to light the
covert operations of the United States
government and that's very difficult to
do especially in an open trial and that
makes him an antihero I think he holds
up fine
the book untold history United States we
go into JFK in a bigger context we don't
discuss the assassination we don't get
into specifics of that but the book
really shows our admiration for JFK it
seems like the people like that Kennedy
yeah that they just seem to always at
the end of the day either
somehow get cut out of the picture yeah
violently or otherwise yeah and and
maybe that is why Barack Obama yeah he's
a little more of the centrist than we
want him to be it would be ironic that
well I think he knows that if he goes a
little too far to the left
really well yeah I'm just curious if you
really think that well if I was busy
extraordinary statement well you don't
think just think it's an extraordinary
statement I'm amazed you I'm impressed
you think that I think what his policies
are driven by fear of assassination well
not by fear of ass [ __ ] why what is
that what you said well I'm saying that
you just send it well I didn't say
didn't I didn't say
well I tried take that well I'm saying
that yeah there is I think that's
something that probably he thinks about
at night yeah well change his policies
for that reason oh but I think look I
think he is the center's I think people
saw him as what they wanted to see him
they saw a liberal and he was never
really that much of a liberal and to
call him a socialist is completely I
don't think anybody who's in the center
or at the right would think that he's
the centrist you might think that but he
that everybody else doesn't think but
yeah I don't think that's I don't think
is an insult to say to somebody that he
may modulate his policies because he
because he's afraid of all the hate that
he sees probably get some reports
constantly about threats though happy at
the end of his second term I think one
of the things that we're going to learn
is he's had more assassination threats
than I'm sure and I think the other
thing we will find is that I think he
has always seen himself as the great
mediator of the country that was going
to try to vastly bring together you know
factions and he has tried to do that
whether with with the Affordable Care
Act not Obamacare was that he he pushed
it through no no bill clinton bill
clinton he thought brought people
together welfare reform huge majority
when you go back to american history all
major social legislation has been passed
with large majorities Social Security
Medicare No Child Left Behind Social
Security was welfare you mentioned bill
his big tax raise that pretty much fixed
this economy didn't get one Republican
vote I don't know where you're getting
this Bowles well I don't could do that
major I don't consider that
major social legislation but that's just
more about their nature social it
doesn't then than anything Obama did
because he didn't he didn't even
remember they were saying he didn't lead
on this he left the Congress and the the
psychological trauma to their heads when
the first black president walked into
the White House just bad visual I'm not
a racist but I think some racist
[ __ ] more to try and reach across
the aisle and bring things together than
Barack Obama I'm saying it was easier
because he was reaching across the aisle
to people who didn't have race as part
of the attack there's research on this
point and I'm not talking about people
were elected office but there's research
on this point that shows that people who
have high levels of subconscious this is
different from racism right this is your
brain on race which is negative
associations you don't even know you
have this is why people can sometimes
lock the door when a black president
walks down the street as he told us
because because you have a negative
association you don't even know you have
so this great study in 2009 showed that
Americans who had a very high level of
this implicit bias very high unconscious
negative attitudes about black people
when they were told the exact same piece
of legislation called health care reform
was attributed to Obama did not support
it when they were told it was Bill
Clinton they did and also what about the
guy in Kentucky who was shown you know
I am talking about who said oh boy he
looked at the specifics from the
Affordable Care Act he said I'm against
Obamacare but this looks pretty good
how about the same thing the birther
thing is so fascinating to watch Ted
Cruz rise up he was born in Canada but
born to an American mother and I for one
a lot of other people said for the first
time I heard about ladies an American
he's a natural natural-born American he
made an and appointees natural-born his
mother he didn't have to go through
naturalization and then they take the
worst case of the birth they say oh he
was born in Kenya or he's born in
Indonesia to an American mother of
course but he's not an American it's
even by their the normal pattern he's a
he's eligibly running for president but
they still keep doing I had a guy in the
other day he would not say that this
president was legitimately like the
president they will not four times I
tried to get him to say it and Donald
Trump is still doing as far as I know
they keep doing it because he's black
isn't that obvious George George rub
Romney was born outside the country
because his family left the country so
they could be polygamists and nobody
ever held that against him John McCain
was born in the Canal Zone bare ego is
born out outside the States he was born
in the territory of Arizona it's never
been an issue except for this guy funny
well you know the Muslim with the racist
Christian pastor and the only guy in the
Republican Party who ever stood up first
John McCain tonight woman and I think
that's gonna get down in his testimony
of the one great thing he said this life
was that woman said he's an Arab and he
said no he's not he's an American a good
America just like us right which was not
exactly a compliment to Arab I mean I
remember I know what you're saying he
did stand up for Obama but it was not a
great thing for the Arabs when he said
that he's an Arab no he is it man
[Laughter]
in real time with bill maher Friday
night at 10 past bill and his guests to
her questions right after the show at
hbo.com